This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. In the early hours of the morning, when the air is heavy and the ticking clock runs slow, Randy Gardner would step out into his yard. He would stand beside the giant cactuses he planted and listen to the cars that whizzed by on Highway 54, which runs behind his home in San Diego. Standing in the moonlit shadows, he would call out in agony. But I would go out on the back yard at three in the morning and scream my head off like a wild animal. Many people are familiar with the suffering Randy experienced.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。在清晨的早期，空气沉重，时钟滴答作响，兰迪·加德纳会走到他的院子里。他会站在他种的巨型仙人掌旁，听着呼啸而过54号公路上的汽车，这条公路穿过他在圣迭戈的家后面。站在月光下的阴影中，他会痛苦地呼喊。但我会在凌晨三点走到后院，像野兽一样放声尖叫。许多人都对兰迪经历过的痛苦感到熟悉。
There's a lonely communion that binds those who plead with the gods at 3 o'clock in the morning. No one can help you, no one can make you feel better, no one can do anything. It's like you're going insane. But Randy also knew he was different from everyone else. Many years ago, as a rebellious teenager, he tempted those very same gods. His punishment, he understood, was payback. Thank you again. Have a lovely day. I was in San Diego recently for a conference. I had some downtime so I decided to visit someone I'd been wanting to meet for a long time. Hey! Are you Randy?
有一种孤独的共鸣，将那些在凌晨三点向神明恳求的人紧紧联系在一起。没有人能帮你，没有人能让你感觉好受点，没有人能做任何事。这就像你要疯了一样。但兰迪也知道自己和别人不一样。许多年前，作为一个叛逆的青少年，他曾向那些神明发起挑战。他明白，他的惩罚是因果报应。再次感谢你。祝你今天愉快。我最近为了一个会议去了圣迭戈。我有一些空闲时间，所以我决定去拜访一个我一直想见很久的人。嘿！你是兰迪吗？
Yeah, I'm Randy Shankar. It's so nice to meet you. So nice to meet you. How are you? Randy Gardner greets me in the driveway of his home. He gives me a warm handshake and a smile. He's wearing a lemon colored shirt and sky blue shorts that set off his deep tent. He exudes Southern California charm. Man, you live in paradise.
是的，我是兰迪·尚卡尔。很高兴见到你。很高兴见到你。你好吗？兰迪·加德纳在自家车道上迎接我。他热情地和我握手并微笑着。他穿着一件柠檬黄的衬衫和天蓝色的短裤，衬托出他黝黑的肤色。他散发着南加州的魅力。天哪，你住在人间仙境里。
Not well. It sits okay. Do you have bad weather events here? We have hotter than hell's shit. We're off bikes. Randy lives in a small green and white house surrounded by sandy brown stucco homes. The backyard is next to a noisy freeway.
不太好。这还行。你们这里有恶劣天气吗？我们这里热得像地狱里的狗屎。我们不用骑自行车。兰迪住在一栋小小的绿白相间的房子里，周围是沙棕色的灰泥房屋。后院紧挨着一条吵闹的高速公路。
Randy and his wife, Alona, share their place with a 13-year-old Bengal cat, George. Sorry, what I meant was Prince George. We did not spoil him, he came that way. Randy and Ilona are now retired, which means lots of time to focus on George and their hobbies. These are photographs that I took. The walls are covered with some of his favorite shots,
兰迪和他的妻子阿洛娜和一只13岁的孟加拉猫乔治住在一起。抱歉，我的意思是乔治王子。我们可没有宠坏他，他生来就是这样。兰迪和伊洛纳现在退休了，这意味着有大量时间专注于乔治和他们的爱好。这些是我拍的照片。墙上挂满了她最喜欢的一些照片，
the golden gate in San Francisco, and stacked on the shelves are knick-knacks and toys. At one point in the cross space, I had over 500 puzzles. Oh my God. Our story really begins in 1963 when Randy moved to San Diego. He was 17. It was the last in a long line of childhood moves.
旧金山金门大桥，书架上堆满了小摆设和玩具。有一段时间，在阁楼空间里，我有500多个拼图。哦，天哪。我们的故事真正始于1963年，当时兰迪搬到了圣迭戈。他当时17岁。这是童年频繁搬家中的最后一次。
I'm the oldest of four siblings in a military family. And my father traveled around so we were in different places every two years we lived somewhere else. In every town they lived in, Randy entered the science fair. I was kind of a science nerd when I was young. When we came to this town, San Diego, I thought boy, it's a big city. If you wanted to win in San Diego, he'd have to pull out all the stops. So for 21's time and here from the skyline, it's since I don't have you.
我是军人家庭四个孩子中的老大。我的父亲经常四处奔波，所以我们每两年就会搬到不同的地方生活。在他们住过的每个小镇，兰迪都参加了科学博览会。我年轻时有点像个科学书呆子。当我们来到这个小镇圣迭戈时，我想，哇，这是一个大城市。如果你想在圣迭戈获胜，你就必须使出浑身解数。所以对于21岁的时间以及这里的城市天际线，自从我没有你。
To understand the project he came up with, it's important to know something about the time. Rock and Roll was changing radio and it wasn't just the songs that were gaining notice. It was the DJs playing them. The fabulous 40 of 1959. You're here for the year, aren't you? One of them was Peter Trip, a New York City DJ who hosted Your Hits of the Week on WMGM. The Rock's Rock's Rock's Rock, WMGM. Peter plays an important part in our story. He wanted to stand out in the disc jockey world, and so, in 1959, he came up with a stunt. He announced he was going to do a week-a-thon to raise money for charity. He would go eight days without sleeping and be beyond display the entire time. On January 20th, 1959, Peter began broadcasting from a small glass studio in the middle of
为了理解他想出的这个项目，有必要了解一下当时的时代背景。摇滚乐正在改变广播，受到关注的不仅仅是歌曲。还有播放它们的DJ。1959年的传奇40强。你来这里是为了这一年，不是吗？其中之一是彼得·特里普，他是纽约市的一名DJ，在WMGM主持《你本周的热门歌曲》。The Rock's Rock's Rock's Rock, WMGM。彼得在我们的故事中扮演着重要的角色。他想在唱片骑师的世界里脱颖而出，因此，在1959年，他想出了一个噱头。他宣布他将举办一场马拉松来为慈善事业筹集资金。他将连续八天不睡觉，并且在整个过程中保持直播。1959年1月20日，彼得开始从时代广场
Times Square. Scientists were there to watch. For the next eight days, he hosted a show while fighting off sleep, preening it first, then yawning, eventually hallucinating. One thing he never did, sleep. Peter's Tant invited others. A few months later, a DJ and Honolulu, Tom Rounds, raised the stakes by going 260 hours, more than 10 days without sleep. Intentional sleep deprivation was apparently like the ice bucket challenge for DJs in the 1960s. 17-year-old Randy Gardner,
中央的一个小型玻璃演播室进行广播。科学家们在一旁观察。在接下来的八天里，他一边与睡意作斗争，一边主持节目，先是梳妆打扮，然后打哈欠，最后出现幻觉。有一件事他从未做过，那就是睡觉。彼得的恶作剧吸引了其他人。几个月后，檀香山的DJ汤姆·朗兹将赌注提高到了260小时，即超过10天不睡觉。故意剥夺睡眠显然就像20世纪60年代DJ们的冰桶挑战一样。17岁的兰迪·加德纳，
looking to make his mark on the science fair in a new city, wasn't impressed by these feats. Eight days without sleep, ten days without sleep, big deal, he thought. You don't need a lot of sleep. You don't need sleep. That was the thinking back in the 60s, and that's the thinking that I had. Randy decided to show up the showman. He decided he was going to go without sleep for 264 hours.
渴望在一个新城市的科学博览会上留下自己的印记，对这些壮举并不印象深刻。八天不睡觉，十天不睡觉，有什么大不了的，他想。你不需要很多睡眠。你不需要睡眠。那是60年代的想法，也是我当时的看法。兰迪决定给这位表演者点颜色看看。他决定连续264小时不睡觉。
Exactly 11 days. And when I said, well, let's go 11 days, I wasn't even thinking about any negative things. I was thinking, this really isn't that big of a deal. You know, when it's over, you catch up, you get your sleep, and you go right on by. Even as a teenager, Randy knew that he had a special skill that made him different. I'm a very determined person. When I get things under my crawl, I can't let it go until there's some kind of a solution. He recruited two of his friends, Bruce McAllister and Joe Marciano, and asked them to help keep him awake.
整整11天。当我说话时，好吧，让我们坚持11天，我甚至没有考虑任何负面事情。我在想，这其实真的没什么大不了的。你知道，当它结束时，你会补觉，你得到了睡眠，然后你就可以直接继续前行了。即使在青少年时期，兰迪也知道自己有一种与众不同的特殊技能。我是一个意志非常坚定的人。当我把事情放在心上时，在找到某种解决方案之前，我是无法放手的。他招募了他的两个朋友布鲁斯·麦卡利斯特和乔·马尔西亚诺，并请他们帮忙让他保持清醒。
If you're on your own, you're going to succumb. You're going to fall asleep. Christmas break was coming up and Randy and his friends decided it was the perfect time to break the world record for going without sleep. The first two days were easy. He stayed away from beds and tried to stand as much as he could. But on day three, I noticed that in the morning I was really nauseous and this went on for just about the entire rest of the experiment.
如果你独自一人，你就会妥协。你会睡着的。圣诞假期就要到了，兰迪和他的朋友们决定这是打破不睡觉世界纪录的最佳时机。前两天很容易。他远离床铺，尽量多站着。但在第三天，我注意到早上我真的很恶心，这种情况几乎持续了实验的其余大部分时间。
And that's when I stumbled on eating citrus for some reason. Tangerines or oranges seem to take the nausea away. So your friends, of course, were keeping tabs on you, but they weren't actually accompanying you in the experiment. So what happened? Was one of them, did you have a rotation system, or one of them was always up with you? That exactly was a rotation system,
也就是在那时，我不知怎么地偶然发现了吃柑橘类水果。橘子或橙子似乎能消除恶心。所以你的朋友们当然一直在关注你，但他们其实并没有陪你一起做实验。那么发生了什么？其中一个人是，你们有一个轮流制度，还是其中一个人一直陪着你？那确实是一个轮流制度，
where one would be with me and the other would be sleeping. Or if it was in the daytime, they'd both be with me. Soon, the stunt was attracting television reporters. And that was a good thing because that kept me awake. You know, you're dealing with these people and their cameras and their questions. Did you start to feel like your mental faculties were slipping? That it was harder to answer questions. It was harder to remember something to formulate a phrase or a sentence.
一个人陪着我，另一个在睡觉。或者如果是白天，他们俩都会陪着我。很快，这个噱头就吸引了电视记者。这是一件好事，因为这让我保持清醒。你知道，你在和这些人以及他们的摄像机和问题打交道。你开始觉得自己智力在衰退吗？回答问题变得更难了。记住某些东西、组织一个短语或一个句子变得更难了。
That happened pretty soon. That was that started maybe day four or five and it just kept going downhill. I mean it was crazy where you you couldn't remember things it was almost like an early Alzheimer's thing brought on by lack of sleep. The hardest hours must have indeed been the early hours of the morning that's often when our circadian rhythms are prompting us to be in the deepest sleep, you know, three, four, five o'clock in the morning. What did you do during those hours?
这种情况很快就发生了。大概从第四天或第五天开始，情况就一直在走下坡路。我的意思是这太疯狂了，你记不住事情，这几乎就像是由缺乏睡眠引起的早期老年痴呆症。最艰难的时刻肯定确实是清晨，那通常是我们的昼夜节律促使我们进入最深睡眠的时候，你知道的，凌晨三四五点。你在那些小时里做了什么？
We just kept moving. We always were driving somewhere and driving somewhere and then walking. Most of it involved lots and lots of walking. I played a lot of basketball shooting the hoops. The early hours of the morning were hardest. Everything was closed, everyone was asleep. Randy remembers visiting the local jail. Why did he go to the jail?
我们一直在移动。我们总是在开车去某个地方，开车去某个地方然后走路。大部分涉及大量的大量步行。我打了很多篮球投篮。清晨是最艰难的。一切都关门了，每个人都在睡觉。兰迪记得到当地监狱参观过。他为什么去监狱？
I don't know. Maybe because it was open at three in the morning. We never close. A few days into the wakeathon, a sleep researcher from Stanford University showed up. His name, William Demand. Seriously. And he got a, he got a, he rented a car, a convertible,
我不知道。也许是因为它在凌晨三点开门。我们从不关门。在保持清醒马拉松开始几天后，斯坦福大学的一位睡眠研究员出现了。他的名字叫威廉·德门特。说真的。他弄到了一辆，他租了一辆车，一辆敞篷车，
and we drove around that. So we had a, we had a really good time when Dr. Dement came down. That, that really helped me because that was like a, a fresh of something different and new to keep me going. I understand that Dr. Dement also played a lot of games with you. He, besides sort of doing sort of psychological tests, he was actually, he actually played various, sort of sports with you, is that right? We, we did a lot of pinball.
我们开着它到处转。所以当德门特博士来的时候，我们过得非常愉快。那，那真的帮了我，因为那就像是一股清新、与众不同的新鲜空气，让我坚持下去。据我了解，德门特博士还和你玩了很多游戏。除了做某种心理测试之外，他实际上还，他实际上和你一起玩各种，某种体育运动，是这样的吗？我们，我们玩了很多弹珠台。
How do you do? I did good. I think I beat him most of the time. Actually, Randy won all the time. Physically, I didn't have any problems. Not walking or throwing the basketball around or playing the pinball games. But the metal part is what went downhill.
你玩得怎么样？我玩得很好。我想我大部分时间都赢了他。实际上，兰迪一直都在赢。身体上，我没有任何问题。无论是走路、投篮还是玩弹珠游戏。但是心理部分却走下坡路了。
The longer I stayed awake, the more irritable I got. I had a very short fuse on day 11. I remember snapping at reporters right before I was getting ready to go to sleep after 11 days, and they were asking me these questions over and over and over, and I was just, I was a brat. On January 8th 1964, Randy broke the world record for going without sleep. He'd gone 11 days, 264 hours without drifting off. There was only one way to celebrate. He was whisked off to a naval hospital so researchers could keep an eye on him and he went to sleep.
我醒着的时间越长，我就越烦躁。在第11天，我的脾气变得非常暴躁。我记得在11天后准备睡觉之前，我对记者们发脾气，他们一遍又一遍地问我这些问题，而我只是，我当时像个乳臭未干的小孩。1964年1月8日，兰迪打破了不睡觉的世界纪录。他已经连续11天、264小时没有打瞌睡了。只有一个方法来庆祝。他被迅速送到海军医院，以便研究人员可以盯着他，然后他睡着了。
How long did you sleep? I slept just over 14 hours. I remember when I woke up I was groggy but not any groggy than a normal, normal person. And did you find that over the next several days or weeks you needed extra sleep? No, not at all. I went right back to the regular mode and everything was fine. Strange, isn't it? Randy's sleep project earned him and his friends first place in the 10th annual Greater San Diego Science Fair. It also ushered in a lifetime of fame.
你睡了多久？我睡了刚好超过14小时。我记得当我醒来时我有些头昏脑涨，但并不比一个正常、正常人更头昏脑涨。你发现接下来的几天或几周里你需要额外的睡眠吗？不，一点也不。我直接回到了正常模式，一切都很好。很奇怪，不是吗？兰迪的睡眠项目为他和他的朋友们赢得了第十届大圣迭戈科学博览会的第一名。这也开启了他一生的名气。
a lifetime of fame. This is sound from the popular 1960s TV game show to tell the truth. The show brings together four celebrity panelists, the panelists face three people who all claim to be the same person. My name is Randy Gardner. My name is Randy Gardner. My name is Randy Gardner. The panelists have to guess which one is the real Randy. On the show, the real Randy Gardner is number two. Number two, how long did you sleep the minute you were through with the 11 days and nights? 14 hours and 43 minutes. He looks like Clark Kent. He wears dark, haundry glasses. His hair swoops to the left.
一生的名气。这是20世纪60年代热门电视游戏节目《说出真相》中的声音。节目汇集了四位名人嘉宾，嘉宾们面对三个都声称是同一个人的人。我的名字是兰迪·加德纳。我的名字是兰迪·加德纳。我的名字是兰迪·加德纳。嘉宾们必须猜出哪一个才是真正的兰迪。节目中，真正的兰迪·加德纳是2号。2号，当你完成那11天11夜后，你立刻睡了多久？14小时43分钟。他看起来像克拉克·肯特。他戴着深色的老式眼镜。他的头发向左微卷。
He soft-spoken and direct when answering questions. Most of the panelists figured out that this Randy was the real Randy. I know it's an avenue because he looks asleep. It's not too early, it's rather a dream. But number two, number two, number two. Over the next decade, Randy Gardner's life took different turns. He worked in horticulture, took a stab at photography, and finished up his career working as a stock trader. But whatever he did, his teenage accomplishment stayed with him. I'm some kind of a Bruce Springsteen in the sleep world.
他说话温和，回答问题直截了当。大多数嘉宾都看出这个兰迪才是真正的兰迪。我知道这是一条大道，因为他看起来像睡着了。现在还不太早，这更像是一个梦。但是2号，2号，2号。在接下来的十年里，兰迪·加德纳的人生经历了不同的转折。他从事过园艺工作，尝试过摄影，最后以股票交易员的身份结束了他的职业生涯。但无论他做什么，他十几岁的成就在他身上留下了烙印。我是睡眠世界的某种布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀。
It's a very strange feeling. The teenage stunt was the gift that kept on giving. But Randy was to find that they can be a downside to fame. When we come back, how it all went downhill. And everybody thought I was some kind of ass. of ass. Plenty of people have tried to do what Randy Gardner did, go days on end without sleeping. You can find clips of all their adventures on YouTube. It's Sunday afternoon right now and tonight's day one of going without sleep for the next week.
这是一种非常奇怪的感觉。少年的恶作剧是一份不断带来回报的礼物。但兰迪发现名气也会有阴暗面。当我们回来时，看看这一切是如何走下坡路的。每个人都以为我是某种混蛋。混蛋。很多人都尝试过兰迪·加德纳做过的事，连续几天不睡觉。你可以在YouTube上找到他们所有冒险经历的片段。现在是周日中午，今晚是接下来一周不睡觉的第一天。
I'm about to stay up for three days. This is going to be the hardest challenge I've ever done. But if you're looking to set a new record for going without sleep... I'm quite struggling. I don't quite get it. You're out of luck. The Guinness Book of World Records has eliminated the category, citing the health dangers of severe sleep loss. And I think it's important to keep in mind, by the way,
我打算保持清醒三天。这将是我做过最难的挑战。但如果你想创造不睡觉的新纪录……我很挣扎。我不太明白。你没那么幸运。《吉尼斯世界纪录大全》已经取消了这一类别，理由是严重睡眠不足对健康的危害。顺便说一句，我认为记住这一点很重要，
this is UC Berkeley neuroscientist Matthew Walker, that Guinness does seem to deem it acceptable for a man, I believe it was Felix Baumgartner, to ascend to the very outer reaches of Earth's atmosphere in a capsule, in a spacesuit, get out of that capsule, and then free fall back down to earth, breaking the sound barrier with his body, traveling at well over 1000 kilometers per hour. That deemed as okay to do. Sleep deprivation, because of its deathly consequences no longer. So I hope that frames the disease-related risk that Guinness rightfully recognizes regarding insufficient sleep. Matthew Walker calls himself a sleep diplomat. He spent more than 20
这是加州大学伯克利分校的神经科学家马修·沃克，吉尼斯似乎认为以下行为是可以接受的：一个男人，我相信是费利克斯·鲍姆加特纳，穿着太空服乘太空舱上升到地球大气层的最外层边缘，从太空舱里出来，然后自由落体回到地球，用他的身体突破音障，以每小时远超1000公里的速度移动。这被认为是允许做的。至于剥夺睡眠，由于其致命的后果，不再允许了。所以我希望这能框定吉尼斯正确认识到的关于睡眠不足的与疾病相关的风险。马修·沃克称自己为睡眠外交官。他花了两十多年的时间
years studying the topic, and he's written a book titled Why We Sleep. If your idea of being sleep deprived as days on end without enough rest, Matthew says, think again, even just the smallest amount of insufficient sleep we seek health consequences. And I think perhaps one of the best examples of that small perturbation is that one of the largest sleep experiments ever done. It's been performed on 1.6 billion people. It happens twice a year and it continues to happen. It's called daylight savings time. And in the spring when we lose an hour of sleep, we see a subsequent 24% increase in heart attacks.
研究这个主题，并且他写了一本名为《为什么要睡觉》的书。如果你认为睡眠不足就是连续几天休息不够，马修说，再想想吧，即使只是极少量的睡眠不足也会带来健康后果。我想这种微小扰动最好的例子之一就是曾经做过的最大的睡眠实验之一。它已经在16亿人身上进行了。它每年发生两次，并且还在继续发生。这叫做夏令时。在春天，当我们失去一个小时的睡眠时，我们看到心脏病发作率随后增加了24%。
In the fall, when we gain an hour of sleep opportunity, there is a 21% decrease in heart attacks. So that's how fragile our brain and bodies can be to even just the smallest fluctuations of sleep. So we don't have to go to the Randy Gardner extreme of 11 days, just one hour of sleep is all that it takes to show these types of demonstrable consequences in terms of ill health.
在秋天，当我们获得一个小时的睡眠机会时，心脏病发作率下降了21%。这就是我们的的大脑和身体对于哪怕只是最小的睡眠波动是多么脆弱。所以我们不必达到兰迪·加德纳那种11天的极端情况，仅仅一个小时的睡眠不足就足以在健康不佳方面显示出这些可证明的后果。
If you do the math, 11 days times 8 recommended hours of sleep a night, that's 88 hours of sleep that Randy missed. When he finally went to bed, he slept only 14 hours. The human brain is not capable of getting back all of the sleep that it has lost. So, sleep in this regard is not like the bank. You can't accumulate a debt and then pay it off at some later point in time. There isn't a credit system in the brain or the body. And we can ask by the way why? Why isn't there something like that? Wouldn't that be wonderful? And there is precedent there, that sells. So there were times in evolution when we would have feast and there were times when
如果你算一下，11天乘以每晚推荐的8小时睡眠，那是兰迪错过的88小时睡眠。当他终于上床睡觉时，他只睡了14小时。人类的大脑无法补回它所失去的所有睡眠。所以，在这方面，睡眠不像银行。你不能积累债务然后在稍后的某个时间点还清。大脑或身体中没有信用系统。顺便我们可以问一下为什么？为什么没有这样的东西？那不是很棒吗？而且有先例，细胞就是这样的。所以在进化过程中，我们有时会丰衣足食，有时会有
there was famine. And we designed a system to come up and store that caloric credit, and so that we could spend it when there was a debt. There may be a reason our bodies don't do this. The right analogy to sleep might not be eating, but breathing. You can't say, I'll skip today and catch up on my breathing tomorrow. For a long time, Randy simply bathed in the celebrity that his stunt had brought him. He'd found a way to cheat sleep. Life was in the celebrity that his stunt had brought him. He'd found a way to cheat sleep.
饥荒。我们设计了一个系统来出现并储存这种热量信用，以便我们可以在有债务时花费它。我们的身体不这样做可能是有原因的。对睡眠正确的类比可能不是吃东西，而是呼吸。你不能说，我今天不呼吸了，明天把呼吸补回来。很长一段时间里，兰迪只是沐浴在他的恶作剧带给他的名气中。他找到了一种欺骗睡眠的方法。生活在他的恶作剧带给他的名气中。他找到了一种欺骗睡眠的方法。
Life was good for him and his wife, Ilona. The focus of our life is pretty much George. George the cat, that teenage Bengal. Randy and Ilona love George. I don't know much about cats, but apparently, Bengals have the personality of a dog. They fetch a cat that defaches. Are you serious? He doesn't do much anymore.
他和妻子伊洛纳的生活过得很好。我们生活的重心几乎就是乔治。乔治那只猫，那只十几岁的孟加拉猫。兰迪和伊洛纳非常爱乔治。我对猫了解不多，但显然，孟加拉猫有狗的性格。它们会捡回东西，一只会捡东西的猫。你是认真的吗？他现在不怎么动了。
Listening to Randy and Ilona, ooze with affection for George is very sweet. When I came to visit, Ilona was getting ready to take George to the vet. They're very meticulous about his health. That's partly because, a decade ago, there was another cat in Randy and Ilona's life. She died of a tongue cancer partly because a decade ago there was another cat in Randy and Ilona's life. She died of a tongue cancer and I was so upset that the vets didn't catch it that they
听着兰迪和伊洛纳对乔治流露出满满的爱意非常甜蜜。我去拜访时，伊洛纳正准备带乔治去看兽医。他们对他的健康非常一丝不苟。部分原因是，十年前，兰迪和伊洛纳的生活中还有另一只猫。她死于舌癌，部分原因是十年前兰迪和伊洛纳的生活中还有另一只猫。她死于舌癌，我非常沮丧，因为兽医没有发现它，他们
never looked in her mouth to find this tumor that they blamed every other thing and then she died and I was so racked with guilt which is stupid. You know I would never do that. Now you have to move forward. You can't go back. But I didn't then. And I think that's what triggered it. The it, Randy's referring to, is insomnia.
从来没有检查过她的嘴来发现这个肿瘤，他们把其他一切都归咎于此，然后她死了，我充满了负罪感，这太愚蠢了。你知道我永远不会那样做。现在你必须向前看。你不能回头。但我当时没有。我想这就是引发它的原因。那个“它”，兰迪指的是失眠。
About 10 years ago, I stopped sleeping. I could not sleep. I would lay in bed for five, six hours sleep, maybe 15 minutes, that wake up again. And I kept thinking, well, this will change because it seems to me that eventually, if you don't get enough sleep, your body will just say, we're going to sleep,
大约10年前，我停止了睡眠。我无法入睡。我会在床上躺五、六个小时，睡大约15分钟，然后又醒了。我一直认为，嗯，这会改变的，因为在我看来，最终，如果你睡眠不足，你的身体只会说，我们要睡觉了，
but it never happened. The man who conquered sleep was now begging for a full-night rest. That's why I keep calling this some, some, some karmic payback for, you know, my body going, okay buddy, yeah, okay, 11 days without sleep and you know, damn well, you need sleep. Well, let's try this out for size. Randy says going without sleep changed him. And everybody thought I was some kind of ass.
但这从未发生。这个曾经征服睡眠的男人现在却在乞求一个完整的夜间休息。这就是为什么我一直称这为某种，某种，某种业力报应，你知道，我的身体在说，好吧老兄，是的，好吧，11天不睡觉，而且你心知肚明，你需要睡眠。好吧，让我们试试这个尺码合不合适。兰迪说不睡觉改变了他。每个人都以为我是某种混蛋。
What's wrong with Randy? What an asshole. There's all kinds of ways to go to sleep, they say. You know, watch television, read a book, and I'm thinking, you know, if you can't sleep in the first place, reading a book isn't going to put you to sleep. I got news for you. I don't know where they came up with that one. Read a book, watch TV. No, no, no. If you have that kind of a serious problem, you're done. Day in and day out, for years on end, Randy began to feel the way he'd felt at the end of his sleep stunt. Except this time, there were no TV cameras, no reporters, no prizes.
兰迪怎么了？真是个混蛋。他们说，有各种各样的方法可以入睡。你知道，看电视，读一书，而我在想，你知道，如果你一开始就睡不着，读一本书并不会让你睡着。我有个消息要告诉你。我不知道他们是从哪儿想出这一招的。读本书，看电视。不，不，不。如果你有那种严重的问题，你就完了。日复一日，年复一年，兰迪开始感到他在他的睡眠恶作剧结束时的那种感觉。只是这一次，没有电视摄像机，没有记者，没有奖品。
I was awful to be around. Everything upset me. It was like a continuation of what I did 50 years ago. We don't know what triggered Randy's insomnia, but this some anecdotal evidence that prolonged sleeplessness can really mess up the brain. Remember Peter Trip, the radio DJ who inspired Randy with his wakeathon? Here are psychiatrists Floyd Cornelison, who monitored Peter, speaking on the television series, Secrets of Sleep. The man I saw the first morning that he began this, when he was waving at everybody to the class winners
我很难相处。每件事都让我心烦意乱。这就像是我50年前所做事情的延续。我们不知道是什么引发了兰迪的失眠，但有一些轶事证据表明，长期失眠确实会搞砸大脑。还记得彼得·特里普吗？那个用他的清醒马拉松激励了兰迪的电台DJ？这里是监控彼得的精神病学家弗洛伊德·科内利森在电视系列剧《睡眠的秘密》中发表的讲话。我看到他开始这个的第一天的那个人，当时他向班上的赢家挥手
and smiling and laughing and joking with us, after the 200 hours had become a change in the visual. In the months that followed, trips seemed unable to recover his center of gravity. He fought with his boss and lost his job. He ended up as a salesman drifting from time to time across America. Those that knew him well were convinced that those eight days without sleep had left him permanently damaged.
微笑着、笑着、开着玩笑，在200小时之后，视觉发生了变化。在随后的几个月里，特里普似乎无法恢复他的重心。他与老板争吵并失去了工作。他最终成了一个推销员，在美洲各地流浪。那些熟悉他的人确信，那八天不睡觉让他受到了永久性的损害。
So some of that might have been hyperbole. Still, Randy thinks what happened to Peter was real, and his age might have been a factor. That's why I don't think you can do this kind of thing unless you're 17 or in that age group. I know I couldn't do it now, and I wouldn't do it now, because I have more sense. After a decade of insomnia in his 60s, Randy finally made an uneasy piece with sleep. He's regained the ability to drift off, but only for about six hours a night,
所以其中一些可能有些夸大其词。不过，兰迪认为彼得发生的事情是真的，他的年龄可能是一个因素。这就是为什么我认为除非你17岁或在这个年龄段，否则你不能做这种事。我知道我现在做不到，我今天也不会这么做，因为我更有理智了。在60多岁时经历了十年的失眠之后，兰迪终于与睡眠达成了不安的妥协。他恢复了入睡的能力，但每晚只能睡大约六个小时，
and it's required sacrifice. I love drinking tea, and to this day I can't drink tea because I'm afraid I won't be able to sleep at night. You have to have sleep. It's as important as it's the big through. I call it the big three water food sleep. You got to have them all of them. Randy Gardner, the man who conquered sleep, now lives in mortal fear of going a night without it. On the next episode of Hidden Brain, we're going to dive deeper into the science of sleep with neuroscientist Matthew Walker. If we didn't need 8 hours of sleep and we could survive on six,
而且这需要付出牺牲。我喜欢喝茶，直到今天我还是不敢喝茶，因为我害怕晚上睡不着。你必须有睡眠。它和三大要素一样重要。我称之为三大要素：水、食物、睡眠。你必须拥有所有这些。兰迪·加德纳，这个征服了睡眠的男人，现在对度过一个不眠之夜怀有致命的恐惧。在下一集的《隐藏的大脑》中，我们将与神经科学家马修·沃克一起深入探讨睡眠科学。如果我们不需要8小时的睡眠，靠6小时就能存活，
Mother Nature would have done away with 25% of our sleep time millions of years ago. Because when you think about it, sleep is an idiotic thing to do. So if sleep does not provide a remarkable set of benefits, then it's the biggest mistake the evolutionary process processes ever made. This episode of Hidden Brain was produced by Parts Shah and edited by Jenny Schmitt and Tara Boyle. Our team includes René Clar, René Cohen and Maggie Penman. For more Hidden Brain, please follow us on Facebook, Twitter and Instagram. If you like our show, tell your friends about us and make sure you're subscribed to the podcast so you don't miss a single episode.
大自然早在几百万年前就会剥夺我们25%的睡眠时间了。因为仔细想想，睡觉是一件愚蠢的事情。所以如果睡眠没有带来显着的好处，那么这就是进化过程中犯下的最大错误。本期《隐藏的大脑》由帕尔茨·沙阿制作，珍妮·施密特和塔拉·博伊尔编辑。我们的团队包括勒内·克拉尔、勒内·科恩和玛吉·彭曼。想了解更多《隐藏的大脑》，请在脸书、推特和Instagram上关注我们。如果你喜欢我们的节目，请告诉你的朋友，并确保订阅了播客，这样你就不会错过任何一集。
Writing a review on iTunes or other podcast platforms also helps other people find the show. Thanks so much for making the time to do it. Our unsung hero this week is Susie Cummings. I spent two weeks trying to track down Randy Gardner, who might interviewed many years ago when I was working at the Washington Post. I couldn't find his phone number, so I reached out to Susie, and of course, in no time flat, she tracked down his number. That's what you do if you're a research librarian at NPR. Thanks Susie.
在iTunes或其他播客平台上写评论也有助于其他人找到这个节目。非常感谢你们抽出时间这样做。我们这周的无名英雄是苏茜·卡明斯。我花了两周时间试图追踪兰迪·加德纳，多年前我在《华盛顿邮报》工作时曾采访过他。我找不到他的电话号码，所以我联系了苏茜，当然，在转眼之间，她就查到了他的号码。如果你是NPR的研究图书管理员，你就会这样做。谢谢苏茜。
I'm Shankar Vitaantham, and this is NPR. I hope you sleep well tonight. I'll talk to you very soon. This is NPR. I hope you sleep well tonight. I'll talk to you very soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这里是NPR。希望你今晚能睡个好觉。我们很快再聊。这里是NPR。希望你今晚能睡个好觉。我们很快再聊。这一集还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子来发表评论。